hello and welcome to this news
conference bonjour bienvenue conference
depressed i'm elizabeth thompson with
cbc news
with us today we have dr teresa tam and
dr new who will be presenting their
latest report on coven 19.
doctors
thank you good morning bonjour 232 today
we will provide the latest update on
national epidemiology with a focus on
the longer term management of covet 19
and prepare us for the future
for more than two years the covet-19
pandemic has had a profound and
significant impact on the health social
and economic well-being of people in
canada and globally thanks to our
collective whole of society response we
have learned more about how the virus
behaves and we are better equipped with
new tools including diagnostics a
portfolio of six health canada
authorized 19 vaccines and more
treatment options
together these tools can help reduce the
impact and severity of covet 19.
we're now in a period of transition and
we anticipate that progress will not be
linear and that it will likely there
will likely be more bumps along the way
including resurgence in cases this
spring and likely also in the fall and
winter
however with higher levels of population
immunity proven protective practices to
slow the spread and reduce pressure on
the health system we are in a stronger
position to get back to more of the
things we love while continuing to keep
each other safer
nevertheless as we take steps to recover
address the broader impacts of the
pandemic and actively prepare for a
range of future scenarios we're all
encouraged to keep vaccinations up to
date and continue with the personal
protective measures like masking
slide one following the last update in
february jurisdictions across the
country eased public health measures
not unexpectedly the associated increase
in in-person activities more
transmissible ba2 variants and waning
immunity may have contributed to
increases in transmission as reflected
in recent trends in daily new case
counts laboratory positivity and other
indicators of increased virus
circulation
as of march the 31st daily average case
counts have increased by 28 nationally
indicating a resurgence is underway
currently declines in lagging indicators
of severe illness are leveling off as
with disease activity indicators these
trends show considerable variability
regionally and unlikely to follow the
rising trends of cases to some degree
over the coming weeks
over the same time period surveillance
activities have been shifting from
reporting every case to monitoring key
trends at the population level with
reduced frequency of reporting
as we continue through this transition
phase we need to further build on the
range of surveillance activities that
were established and enhanced throughout
the pandemic
these will continue to support early
warning and ongoing monitoring of
disease activity while being adapted for
longer term sustainable disease
monitoring
dear positive
a luckily
intensified
slide three
as part of a comprehensive surveillance
approach examining wastewater trends can
help us understand patterns of covet-19
transmission in our communities
this approach has several important
advantages
including potential to act as an early
warning system
providing a source of data that can help
estimate the burden of covert 19 as well
as identify virus variants circulating
in communities
while some sites are currently showing
rising virus levels in community
wastewater there's variability across
testing sites for example recently
reported community wastewater data
signal
a rising trend in a number of local
areas such as ottawa while there are
signs of declining signals for several
sites in saskatchewan
with information like this in hand
people may be encouraged to adjust their
use of personal practices such as
masking to protect themselves and others
it is important to remember that no
single source of information can tell
the whole story going forward it will be
important to continue to monitor a range
of surveillance indicators
dear positive cat
bianca plute
foreign slide five over the longer term
coven 19 activity will depend on a range
of factors
including waning immunity
therefore ongoing monitoring of covit-19
vaccine's impact can support vaccination
programming going forward
since vaccines became available
hospitalization rates have been
consistently lower among fully
vaccinated people and those with an
additional dose compared to unvaccinated
people
from mid-february to mid-march
vaccinated people continue to be at
lower risk of hospital admissions than
unvaccinated within hospitalization rate
that was four times lower among fully
vaccinated people than among the
unvaccinated people and 10 times lower
among fully vaccinated people with an
additional dose than among unvaccinated
people
getting an mrna booster dose remains
important for enhancing your overall
immune response which can provide longer
lasting protection and possibly better
effectiveness against variants
dear positive sis actual music typically
seven globally some countries that
passed the peak of the omicron wave have
since begun to see signs of a resurgence
canada has been closely monitoring the
situation in these countries
particularly as it relates to the spread
of the ba2 sublineage
predominance of ba2 appears to be common
among countries currently reporting a
resurgence of cases and in the context
of less stringent public health measures
this cautions us in canada to continue
to prepare for further ups and downs of
the trajectory including the spring as
ba2 continues to spread and in light of
reduced public health missions this is
why we are urging people to continue
with our vaccines plus strategy by
keeping vaccines up to date
following public health advice and
maintaining good personal protective
habits
dear positive with
the kobe disney
zone
well this is a time to recover in light
of potential scenarios we are
transitioning to sustainable management
of kovin 19 at the same time as we're
preparing for future waves including a
worst case scenario
fortunately canada's overall high
vaccination coverage together with
public health measures and adapting our
daily routines have provided us with
better protection going forward
although further ups and downs are not
unexpected over the coming months we can
continue to rely on the suite of tools
we have for prevention surveillance and
response including vaccines testing
treatments and public health and
healthcare infrastructure
for public health and individuals alike
maintaining a caution and a state of
readiness
will be our strongest
advantage as we prepare and enhance our
search capacity for future response
measures to reduce transmission will
continue to be important particularly in
high exposures risk settings
and around vulnerable populations
for individuals and families this
includes keeping over 19 vaccinations up
to date including getting a boost to
those when eligible
being aware of our evolving risks in our
community and maintaining individual
protective practices such as wearing
masks staying home when sick and
improving ventilation of indoor spaces
in particular as ramadan passover easter
and other important events approach
considering the risks and planning safer
ways to celebrate but continuing to use
good personal protective habits can help
keep us all safer and collectively
reduce the risk of large spreading
events for the ongoing efforts of
countless canadians and protecting each
other thank you merci megridge
dear positive nerf
hello
foreign thank you merci beaucoup uh we
now go to questions uh the first person
who will be asking questions is dylan
robertson from the winnipeg free press
uh dr tim you mentioned a shift from
reporting every case to monitoring key
trends but that shift seems unparalleled
among our pure countries when we look at
the per capita number of tests being
performed canada is way at the bottom of
the 38 countries of the oecd i wanted to
know if you're comfortable with that
happening on your watch
i think as as you know um
the tests were
being done by province and territories
in from a federal perspective we have
supported capacity building
provided
and many other resources and other
supports
to province and territories
we know that
at the peak of the omicron wave
even though
health systems were stretched provinces
were able to surge to
i believe
even up to a 150 000 tests a day we had
about 40 000 tests a day on average
i can't tell you whether that's too much
or too little but it needs to be enough
so that we can monitor trends of things
going up and down
um and certainly i will be encouraging
province and territories to continue
to
sustain that infrastructure as well as
offering tests to their populations
i know that it was a very difficult task
during the height of the omicron wave
to provide that response
and so i think um
they are just i think the jurisdictions
are adjusting to what is a uh good
sampling size and um
distribution into in in terms of trends
analysis
so which is why we have also added in
supports for waste water monitoring
because we know just like other
respiratory viruses
um not every person will present for
testing some people may have done the
rapid test and you know that's not
counted
and so adding in another layer of
surveillance will give us more
information so that the public can know
what to do
so it's not just one system but many
that needs to be strengthened i think at
this time
uh thanks for the thorough answer and
another question on data you mentioned
collaboration with the provinces to get
consistent data reporting we have seen a
bit of what appears to be a reversal uh
manitoba changed the definition of a
coveted death for the first time in two
years there's other provinces that are
modifying their key indicators i think
this is actually your first modeling
report that has no manitoba data which i
have to assume is the result of the
province pulling the plug on most of its
surveillance
should we be concerned about a
backtracking here if we can no longer
consistently compare the data sets with
the past figures or between the
provinces
yes we've um haven't shown every single
jurisdiction um so that data is either
on our website or can be provided
but yeah so the provinces are all trying
to find their you know steady state or
sustainable uh surveillance approach but
it is important i think to maintain that
as i've just said in my previous answer
to maintain that capacity and i um meet
with as you know the provinces all the
time
very frequently to try and get that
more consistent approach and get the
definitions
so that we can report more consistently
so we we are continuously trying to
improve
and
see where we can
end up in terms of our sustainable
approach going on
i think things like mortality
surveillance is very important and i i
personally think that in the canadian
context we need to do better
during the pandemic we learn to be more
real time
we live with imperfections and with um
some variability
in how we report because we have to be
more timely
i do think now taking some time to
arrive at what might be a good
consistent approach uh would be very
important i'll be really disappointed if
we did
if we went backwards and let go of the
actual gains that we made during this
pandemic and and i look forward to
working in my colleagues
to make sure we're strengthening that
kind of reporting going forwards
thank you merci um i also forgot to
mention if you want to ask a question
please use the raised hand function
question say boris
um
is
um
pcie
um
next question glenn mcgregor ctv
hi uh thank you um in your previous uh
modeling press conferences you provided
graphs that uh provide some projections
on the number of cases um number of
deaths in various scenarios you haven't
done that here is that because you just
don't have the surveillance data to
effectively model which way this is
headed
yeah there's a few reasons one is that
the case data is
more unstable so the confidence
intervals are quite wide in those
estimates and
but the bottom line is
the the the message about resurgence and
the impact hasn't changed since our last
modeling i mean that we actually expect
resurgence to occur any time a
jurisdiction is going to release
the public health measures and increase
contact rates that's just absolutely
expected
and that's what the model will show
um
i think
just to supplement what dr news just
said
um there are variabilities across canada
in terms of um
you know case in increases if we if you
go on our website you will see some maps
and there's 42 health regions where
there's increased incidence this week
um and others in in which that hasn't
occurred but i i would suggest that in
anywhere in canada resurgence could
occur this this in the coming days or
weeks when measures are relaxed
so um
what the
model projections are still showing is
that because of our immunization and
some of the population immunity and the
infection of that big omicron wave we
just had the impact on health systems
such as hospitalizations
is
likely to be lower
that's not a guaranteed in every area of
the country because of the differences
in vaccine coverage and in um other
parameters in terms of who got hit by
the ba1 uh wave more than others so i
think the bottom line is everybody right
now i think
should still wear their mask and keep
those layers of measures
no matter where you are in this country
because even if you don't see a
resurgence now you're probably going to
in the next days weeks and that will
help uh reduce transmission
and
make sure that the impact on the health
system is lowered and please do go get
that booster
uh people think it's maybe too late we
don't need it we just had the infection
any adult over the 18 years of age
when you're eligible go get the booster
nail because that will protect you
further
and the other message is that even if
you got infected
or you think you got infected
the national advisory committee on
immunization recommends a booster three
months after that infection
so that's what i would encourage
everybody to do but the modeling is not
going to show anything different so we
didn't think that was particularly
helpful to um messaging today on the
topic of boosters that number seems kind
of stuck uh in the high 40s
why do you think more people are not
getting their boosters and now you have
you're talking about waning immunity of
people who have had their first two
shots so they need them why is that
number not going up faster is it because
the
public health messaging from the
premiers and the provincial level is
contrary to what you're telling us today
um i think there's diverse reasons but
if you look at and i i don't quite have
in front of me which slide but
what is really great
is that the oldest age groups have high
booster coverage
and as you've probably heard um there's
there's been some news that's the
national advisory committee on
immunization is looking at whether they
need a second booster
i think what i'm trying to message today
is that if you're 50 plus
there's a gap in that vaccine coverage
and getting that boost of those
more than anything else tries to protect
you from severe outcomes it's not too
late go get it because hospitalizations
as you've clearly seen in another slide
it really helps dampen
your personal risk of severe outcomes
and the impact on the health system
but i think there's a
number of varied reasons
so
i think for the many people
got
omicron many people thought they had
omicron and maybe think well now we
don't need another booster that's quite
possible or they're waiting for that
three-month mark so we might see still
see some uptake
uh past you know three months on from
the peak of the
omicron wave that's possible
but i think
there's some misconceptions about um
you know some of the vaccine
effectiveness
um some people might think well you told
us two was enough and now you're saying
three and maybe even four
well i think our knowledge evolves and
we're giving the best advice based on
what we're seeing
and it is
so important for you to keep following
uh that advice and then of course there
is a group of individuals who may not
want to get vaccinated
we have other vaccine options
being made more available
as it stands this week we got our first
delivery of novavax vaccine
and given this uptick in cases
i would
encourage anyone who hasn't been
vaccinated particularly the ones who
haven't even had the primary series to
take advantage of this opportunity i
think in the next days and the next
couple of weeks you'll see the provinces
being able to deploy that
so all of these things might help
um but i think um you know don't don't
be complacent in thinking this is over
even if the wave is slightly smaller
you can do everything that you can
do
in terms of boosters and masking to help
us get back to all the things that we
all want to do
[Music]
uh
um
um
next question erica ibrahim from
canadian press
hi there um
i uh i heard some of my francophone
colleagues
pose this question and i was hoping to
pose it in english
dr tam what do you think of the general
trend of jurisdictions relaxing uh
restrictions at a time um
uh when case counts seem to be on the
rise is now the time to be easing
restrictions and um as a i guess a
follow-up is easing up responsible for
um the the modeling
sure the increase in the activity in a
way is totally expected because any time
we relax
some of these measures and increase
in-person activities or more contacts
cases are going to go up
and that everyone knew about that
on top of that
there's the ba2 variant which
based on the information we have
internationally is more transmissible
and that particularly is going to affect
people who haven't
been up to date with a vaccination or
haven't had that ba1
wave as much in their community and
waning immunity may have occurred in
some populations so all these things
alone it's not just
did someone relax mask mandates that is
not as a singular
you know decision
would be responsible for resurgence it's
a combination i think of all those
things but any time we relax measures
cases go up so the key is whether we can
keep those hospitalizations and severity
trends down but keeping transmission
lower
we can all do because that protects um
the the persons who are at the higher
risk
as well as keeping that uh population
impact lower
um so so i think
we can't see every uptake as being
um you know a massive issue
but we have to still keep at it in terms
of uh trying to dampen that wave as much
as we can
uh while our boosters are still
um you know there's some gaps in our
booster coverage
uh but but you know this is a very
different situation than we were and
it's still going to be very difficult
because balancing transmission and
reducing transmission
and
the reducing severity against the need
for society to return to more normal
stance it's going to be quite a
difficult balance and that's why i think
people have to watch that every
you know very much on an ongoing basis
but as individuals we can still keep up
with those measures
and go get your booster
okay erica did you have a second
question
uh no it was a bit of a double-barreled
question so that was my i rolled my
follow in there too thank you okay yes
and does anyone else want to ask a
question
if so please use the raised hand
function
and seeing no raised hands
thank you very much the census press
conference